Two men started trading Bitcoin on the
exact same day. One spent 12 hours a day
staring at candles, chasing every green
pump. Last night, a single whale trap
liquidated his entire life savings. The
other man, he enjoyed dinner with his
family, slept soundly, and woke up to a
$5,000 profit. The difference wasn't
luck. It was the system. One was the
hunter, the other was the defender. Most
traders fail because they play the
whales game. They buy when they're told
to buy, but the whales are setting traps
and you are the prey. Trap defense BTC
changes the game by visualizing the
invisible. Our engine spots
institutional manipulation before it
hits your P&L. We give you the ultimate
trading skill, the discipline to stay
safe until the odds are in your favor.
It's highresolution defense for a high
stakes market. And today you can equip
yourself for zero cost. Join the
Defenders Academy now and get the
minimum edition of the trap score for
free. No credit card, no fluff, just the
raw truth of the market. Stop being the
prey, become the defender. Click below
to start the bot and claim your free
access now.